president biden will be traveling to
saudi arabia in the middle of july and
he's expected to meet with crown prince
mohammed bin salman also known as mbs
who is the de facto ruler of that
kingdom this is the prince that
president biden said he wanted to make a
pariah because of his involvement in the
murder of the washington post columnist
and saudi dissident jamal khashoggi in
2018. but biden's effort to isolate the
prince were a miserable failure no other
world leader joined in shunning the
prince no costs were imposed on saudi
arabia or the house of saud now biden
needs the prince to do him a favor the
price of gas for american consumers is
at record highs in part because of
russia's invasion of ukraine and biden
needs those gas prices to come down
before the midterm elections in the fall
the only person who can do that
is
the ruler of saudi arabia who can open
up the tap and let more crude oil into
the international system and help bring
crises down so it's the prince and not
the president who has the upper hand in
these negotiations what does mbs want
from biden well first he wants an act of
contrition a kind of apology for that
pariah comment and biden is in effect
giving him that by going to saudi arabia
and meeting him the second thing he
wants is an assurance that this nuclear
deal that biden wants to sign with the
iranians who are saudi arabia's great
enemies that that deal will not put at
risk saudi interest that the iranians
will not then be free to bully the
saudis and their arab neighbors and that
if that happens the united states will
double down on protecting the south and
the third thing he wants is reassurance
that the american security umbrella
which has been provided to his family
the house of saud his country for
decades now will remain against all
enemies most of these things that mbs
wants is actually in america's interest
to give there is a big overlap in saudi
interests and american interests so it
should be possible for biden to make the
deal that the prince wants
[Music]